executive producer chuck laurie's new
series is called
be positive it follows a recently
divorced father named drew
who needs a kidney transplant when he
runs into his old high school friend
gina at a wedding
she drunkenly offers to be his donor
since his family and friends can't help
drew accepts her offer
but he needs to keep gina and his future
kidney
safe and sober do you mind if we switch
seats i just
i want to keep an eye on my motorcycle
oh uh sure
uh not to be a worrywort but uh if
you're
you really think riding around on
motorcycles is a good idea oh
don't worry i wear a helmet good good
not your brain i'm worried about donor
vanilla latte for donor oh that's me
donor yeah tell people you're giving
away a kidney you get a lot of free
stuff
thomas middleditch plays drew emily
ashford is gina good morning to you both
thanks for being with us
thomas let me start with you because
this is a true in part based on
the true story of of the show's creator
and executive producer uh marco panetta
what did he share with you about what
what he went through
and how did that help you understand
your character
uh my big takeaway is that when you
go through something like uh either
giving or
getting an organ from someone uh you're
basically bonded for life his stories
of him and his donor uh
basically now they're friends that check
in every week
and like talk about their day and their
lives and that's kind of
that's kind of sweet so hopefully
hopefully
emily and i are our lifelong friends
even though we're only pretending to
share organs
emily there's quite an impressive team
by behind this as we mentioned chuck
laurie as
executive producer james burrows
directed he of course
uh co-created cheers and directed will
and grace what's that what's it like to
have that kind of
production star power behind you
well you know it's like bowing at the
feet of comedy masters
i feel like coming you know every day
with my jedi
you know training equipment being like
teach me teach me all the things
um billy gardell said this amazing thing
about chuck laurie he said being on a
chuck glory show
is like playing for the yankees and it
certainly feels like that's
kind of amazing next level next level
dream coming true well
emily uh chuck laurie you mentioned the
yankees i mean
as skipper of the yankees he had a
reputation for being pretty intense but
also
reportedly has mellowed a bit with age
in fact i interviewed him uh a while
back for sunday morning and he had mello
but what was it like to have him on set
i mean what were notes from him like
these days so smart so clear so specific
i mean when i say he's the master he
knows what's up he knows what works and
most of all the thing that's really
special about his shows is there's
they're always based in something um
that i think real
people can connect to and this is one of
those stories that
we all know somebody in our life who's
needed an organ
um and it's like a great reminder that
we should all
check that check that box when we're
getting our driver's license right
yes yeah we're i'm laughing because
we're showing a clip i've watched two
episodes guys so i'm in
in thomas i just want to say this i
loved you in silicon valley playing
richard hendricks so i'm so glad to see
you back on tv
but this is the thing about this thing
he's he's got issues
he's divorced he's got a daughter who's
disconnected
he doesn't seem to have any friends
annalee your character is how shall we
say a bit of a hot mess she's been
around the block a couple of times she
says
she says drew was the only guy i didn't
sleep with in high school and it should
stay that way
but i've heard this described as a buddy
comedy
not a buddy comedy but a survival comedy
thomas can you start us off with what
that means
uh well you know i suppose the survival
comedy is
you know for me obviously it's a show
that you want people to laugh too
and there's gonna be some levity to it
all but in the end
we're talking about a story where
there's where someone is
you know fighting for their survival
fighting for their right to live and
that's basically what
organ donorship is when you get the news
that oh you need a new kidney or
whatever else that might be failing in
your body you have to
figure that out otherwise the
consequences can be kind of
uh severe and i've had people even even
before the show
was airing i had people reaching out
being like hey i'm so glad that uh
there's a show about this because i'm
going through it or
even someone that um i hope this doesn't
sound too alienated but someone that's
on my
my uh pr team gave her kidney to her
mother like yeah it kind of meet people
like wow that's that's so generous and
so i think that's what it means by
survival comedy so
there's going to be some moments where i
think the subject matter really
you know hits home seriously where there
won't be jokes
would you give a kidney to someone
because it got me thinking would i give
a kidney to someone i hadn't seen in 30
years and my answer was no it was a very
short list of people
but it did make me start thinking about
it anna lee would you
would you donate a kidney i might i
like really truly believe that i would
want to nobody's asked me yet but my mom
actually has had two cornea transplants
so she has
somebody else's eyeballs she's literally
looking through other people's eyes
we tell that joke but it's true so um
it's touched my life in a really
special personal way my mom would
totally be blind without organ donation
annie emily ashford thomas middleditch
thank you both best of
luck best of luck with this series you
can watch be positive
thursday nights at 8 30 7 30 central
right here on cbs